was there another kid in there that was
hiding his wrist going hey trick over
there I didn't find a mummified kid in
there
[Music]
Steve's gonna like this because he just
loves anything where the government uh
gets to do whatever they want yes thank
God thank God Steve loves everything
about government
especially like when they control our
monitor Supply like yeah the very
controlling ones are his favorite so
this one happened in India
um basically a government official was
standing by the reservoir trying to take
a selfie with his phone and then he
dropped it into the water
um so what he did that's what he got he
ordered the reservoir to be drained and
two million liters of water was wasted
so this guy could find his phone it was
a really good selfie though million
liters yeah what a [__] [__] that
sounds like not in America it's in India
wait could they not just I didn't say
that it's four it's what four and a half
million gallons didn't miss that oh God
so he drained that's him under the
umbrella he drained that whole Reservoir
just to find his phone and did he find
it
yeah but it didn't work anyway did he
think it was gonna work it didn't work
no it was broken did he try to soak it
in rice how long was it in there I don't
know he didn't soak it in rice and
basmati rice I think like maybe a day
and a half or two days soaked some more
I think it took two a day and a half to
like drain that hole oh that's why why
didn't they just send a [__] scuba
diver in there so I wasted all that
water dude and now the village is
waterless true story two months ago I
wake up to Nikki screaming not because
she's riding my dick for once right yeah
hey let's go no so so I was like what
the [__] going on so I go downstairs
and like Nikki I guess she had been it's
windy in Vegas she had been trying to
pull like a [__] deck chair out of
the [__] pool right it does get
really her phone in her pocket and her
phone just right into the pool so she's
like this is not a swim she's like
you know her phone's [__] but the
phone's still floating on the water as
it goes she's yelling honey honey and
all this [__] and I'm like [__]
waking up and like what the [__] is
going on right and so by the time I get
downstairs I just see Nikki completely
naked
completely naked
and she's just and the neighbors are
like this
well thankfully we have fences but she
she like [__] Dives in and she's like
my phone my phone and she Dives in and
gets her phone out was the water cold
freezing it was freezing like did she
get naked I don't know exactly she's
wearing like [__] little pajama
shorts and [__] like they're nice shorts
preserve the shorts like who gives a
[__] it's like some little clothes it's
like a kid she's acting like she's
wearing a whole jumpsuit yeah it's like
it's like a Lethal Weapon movie where
she's like [__] taking her clothes
like oh God damn it all right this is
fine you know but it's like it's a phone
uh so then she yeah she gets her phone
and I thought her phone's [__] I
thought her phone was [__] I was like
why is she even like care but I didn't
know because I have an older phone like
apparently the like newer phone water
resistant yeah she pulls it out and just
it's already working just no way or
nothing yeah that's so cool I didn't
know that though so she was just yelling
so that I would do it but then I'm glad
she [__] did it because it's really
cool so she was hoping you'd come down
and jump in the pool yeah but I didn't
know what the [__] she was talking about
because she's incoherent when like she's
pancake
oh that's that's very Fuji
but Daddy's up today yeah by the time I
realized it was going on she's like
naked and jumping in so I was like I
don't know what's she like I could have
been dying right now and you took so
long
uh thankfully she wasn't that irrational
but she's just glad her phone was
working again that is nice it was
working yeah so yeah this guy's was not
working he actually tried to con the
workers at that Reservoir to do it
because he told them oh the phone has a
sensitive government material on it yeah
right we have to get it and then um that
amount of water it says could have been
used to irrigate 1500 Acres of Farmland
oh my God but he tried to tell media
that that water was unusable for
irrigation and he got permission to
drain it which both of those are lies so
he just how did he just got sick he
literally lied he lied to the because
he's an official so No One's Gonna Come
here don't do this [__] he can do it all
he wants don't do this [__] hey will you
pledge right now in India oh you know
what's funny he's he's a food inspector
he's not even like a like a high like
he's not a mayor he's not like in the
cabinet no he's not a representative Ron
will you pledge that you won't do this
[__] right now you have food inspector
of course not
dude my answer food inspector and when
she goes to restaurants when I went
there and I was kid all the restaurants
would kiss her freaking oh she's the one
that assigns the letter yeah she gives
you the letter so everybody's like oh so
free for free for free oh you like you
like wontons here's two wontons there's
like we just felt like we got treated
like freaking royalty and she was like
it still happens she'll take everything
I know she'll take it yeah she'll take
it you're not supposed to take nothing
no you're not
why because bribery we talked about oh
getting greased up damn it's kind of
worth it though for another one is there
a right way to take things like that
where it's not you do it on the table
you just haven't served the 100 on the
table you just keep pulling food oh my
gosh I'm so sorry we accidentally made
too many literally
one second
you just go hold on real quick it's like
when you tried it
it's like when you're eating during a
meeting or during
pass me the hot dog with the toes put it
in my toes you know when I was a kid you
got fall under the table
when I was a kid I had that feeling so
my uncle he gave me a watch and it was
like a Casio watch and I thought it was
the coolest [__] watch in the world
because it was one of the first ones
where it had hands and it was
um digital thing oh it was like analog
and digital okay yeah yeah and then um
okay this is so [__] cool and I don't
know why but I took the straps off maybe
I was gonna put another strap on or
whatever and I put I kept it in my
pocket I jump in the McDonald's playpen
and I'm playing around whatever when I
come out I go
oh [__] oh [__] off phone no and then
um you said that as a kid too sad yeah I
was like so [__] sad I love that
being that was like my favorite thing
ever and the McDonald's playpen was
probably from like he wanted to drain
the prop I wanted to I mean from this
wall to that to that arcade my uncle is
a food inspector we need to get out of
here I was like no I gotta find this
[__] watch so I got to do the most
systematic way possible so I put my hand
at the far corner of the playpen and I
just dragged it like to that end and
then I went like this like combing the
beach basically combing the whole time
from here I would have gone to the
middle all the way over there and I
still couldn't find it because it's
stuck in one of the balls up there but
you found some cool [__] though I don't
find [__] you can find some cool
anything oh so find like a diaper or
nothing
was there was your fully loaded was
there another kid in there that was
hiding his wrist going hey trick over
there I didn't find a mummified kid in
there
did you got left behind
it just moves him out of the way before
it's like I'm looking for a watch that
does suck to lose stuff like that though
that's an Indian kid on the side
[Laughter]
yeah you can't tell the staff that like
hey there's a lost item of value I don't
even think I'm just so sad they're gonna
be like and I remember being so [__]
terrible check even at night like I'm
like sleeping I've lost the watch and
then you know when you're when you're a
kid like you're like you hope that you
wake up tomorrow and you don't remember
that feeling yeah I remember waking up
ago
[Laughter]
you wake up it's not just a dream oh
that is sad dude Renzo does that crap to
me does he how old is he now uh he's
four like he does all the time like
he'll be like he loves Target first oh I
know I love Target but it's the funnest
place in the world yeah dude the toys
yeah every single time he didn't get a
toys like I didn't get a toy
you can't always get a toy dude who gets
him the toy the wife huh yeah
no no you know how I know because I go
with taika this is like when he was like
three or four outdaughtered them to
supermarket and then um you'd be like oh
can we get like a Hot Wheels car
something and I'm like what do you mean
like what'd you do did you earn it and
he knows every time I come with mom like
she gets me I was like you [__]
spoiling [__]
yeah yeah make me look like how does Geo
rationalize that that's correct this is
oh it's like a toys okay I'm like no
wonder he has like [__] 4 000 the
same toy I thought it was like like the
other cousins pass it on every time they
go to Target but now like okay so
there's a 4 000 Hot Wheels
I do have the talk with him yet the Hot
Wheels track the talk where you sit him
down and you're like you know like I
gotta just tell you straight up like you
know your mom's a spoiling ass [__]
can't let her get to you yeah okay you
gotta stay strong she's not training you
for life like I'm trying to do you know
it's crazy I got really lucky in this is
like 80s Disneyland and after we I wrote
the you know that Matterhorn the
freaking bobsled ride for the first time
I lost my angels cap it's that black hat
with like a red Bill and it just went
flying and it was like my favorite oh no
I was like five years old I was super
distraught and I don't know if they
still do this but back then
um at the end of the night when you go
back to the gates where you exit they
would have a person that's carrying a
giant like it's almost like a stick like
a like
and it's just got everybody's hats they
for sure don't do that now the hell no
there's too many people do you remember
was that a thing that I remember seeing
I've seen that before and they would
just stand by the gate and then if you
lost your hat you would just pick it off
the thing I don't even know if fedco
would do some [__]
[Music]
foreign